congress passed the long-awaited coveted
relief deal but while it was passed by
an overwhelming majority
there was a handful of lawmakers who
said no some say while there weren't
against the package as a whole they were
disappointed that it didn't focus on
getting americans back to work
those who did vote for it say it's not
perfect democrats do plan to work on a
nova
another that is coveted relief bill when
the new congress convenes after the
first of the year meantime this bill
does provide
thousands more dollars for unemployment
claimants nationwide joe mohler joins us
live with more on how the process would
go joe
we've been seeing a lot of comments
about this online people are concerned
on how deter will transition into these
bonuses that are listed
on this proposal or as it is right now
they're worried that these bonuses won't
go smoothly as it does pass if the
president does sign this
a few weeks ago dieter did address this
they were hoping an extension of the
pool benefits would happen and that is
included in this
they also said they hope the program
remains fairly similar so that the
program can just extend seamlessly with
no extensive computer programming being
required
they said as soon as congress acts they
would update claimants on what happens
next
i did reach out to find out if there
would be any changes we're waiting on
that response now these new bonuses that
are included
on this proposal are three hundred
dollars a week a claimant tells me she
hopes it goes as well as when they were
getting that six hundred dollars in the
cares act
you know the six hundred dollars a week
was a massive help
if it rolls out like it did the six
hundred dollar one there was no
everything for me was smooth i didn't
have a single problem with that
yesterday we shared a few concerns
people had some are wondering if there
will be a delay because right now many
are still waiting on lost wages
assistance we learned week five
of that could take another week to
completely be paid out now the president
still has to sign that
relief bill we're still waiting on an
update from that but coming up here at
six o'clock we do have an update
regarding the bank of america concerns
that many people have been having issues
with
we'll have the update from dieter at six
o'clock reporting live joe mohler eight
news now